hey what is up guys MTV HD here and
welcome to episode number one of dope
tech so this is a completely brand new
series designed specifically to showcase
the best and coolest tech that crosses
my path so whether I get to use it just
once or twice or if it's something I use
on a daily basis basically the only
qualification
is that I think it's dope so anything
with an on button is game so kicking off
episode number one we have actually two
things the new chromecast's for 2015 so
there's actually two of them so like
brothers the chromecast and chromecast
Audio the first chromecast is actually
one of the best selling electronics of
all of last year's so unsurprisingly
this new one is also really good it's
very similar it has a couple of
improvements but mostly still going to
have the same function of turning your
not-so-smart TV into a useful one so
it's an HDMI dongle again and this time
even more of a dongle and now with an
HDMI cable built-in so it has a sort of
a magnet to store it I think the new
design looks decent but I cannot unsee
that beats logo
anyway you find the HDMI port on the
back of your TV plug it in and then add
USB power and then set it up with the
new chromecast app on your smart phone
and you're good to go new features for
this version include 5 gigahertz Wi-Fi
support 802 dot 11ac Wi-Fi support and
multiple internal antennas that can
switch between while it's it's behind
your TV to get the best signal yes it
does come in multiple colors but you'll
probably never see that well it sits
behind your TV but yet past that it's an
updated version of the same chromecast
we're familiar with which is dope
you can mirror your phone's display to
your TV or play chromecast enabled games
or really fire up any chromecast enabled
app and cast to your TV pretty quickly
so yeah it can be a pretty seriously
super useful tool like I said turning a
regular TV or even a good TV into a
great one the one thing it still doesn't
support is 4k so everything you're doing
including gaming is still going to be
1080p but I guess they would want to
push you to Android TV for that but you
know it's even better and smarter than
casting music to your TV
casting music 2 speakers a dedicated set
of speakers so that's exactly what
chromecast Audio is for its chromecast 4
speakers so dongle itself looks almost
exactly the same although I think it
looks pretty neat with the ridges on it
at least and it plugs into any pair of
speakers you might have with the
included three-and-a-half millimeter
Kable or you can go optical or RCA and
then any devices can connect to it and
stream music to that set of speakers so
it's even better than bluetooth because
more than one person can hop on and
connect to the stream on the fly so it
essentially turns a normal pair of
speakers or studio monitors or TV
bookshelf speakers whatever you have
into a connected pair of speakers that
anyone can connect to overall I'm a fan
of chromecast again they're both free
five bucks and get my thumbs up all
right so I've been asked a lot about the
equipment that I use to make these
videos so I'm going to go ahead and
start with one of them that guy at the
camera this is red weapon dragon number
41 yeah told you anything is game for
dope Tek this camera is ridiculous in a
lot of ways actually when describing it
I think it's easier to think of it more
as a small computer with a sensor
attached than a camera it's a really
powerful little machine you may have
heard of red the camera I was using
before was called a red epic dragon epic
being the name of the body and dragon
being the name of the sensor the 6k
dragon sensor technically this new
camera is called the red weapon dragon
so new body same dragon sensor the
full-frame 8k sensor that you guys have
been hearing about is coming out as
another upgrade later this year so does
that mean I'll be shooting an 8k later
this year probably not unlike a lot of
the other stuff on dope tech this camera
is definitely not one that I would just
go around recommending for one I am
fully aware that it is definitely
overkill for YouTube or for web video in
general the files look way better on my
computer than they do here after
YouTube's compression but that's okay
because I still enjoy shooting red and I
learned from the raw workflow every day
and maybe just maybe you can tell
through the final result anyway this is
the forged carbon fiber body which goes
through a different process than a
normal carbon fiber to make it stronger
and lighter SSD reader on the side
customizable buttons on the front and
size as well and a pair of actually
decent stereo mics for scratch audio on
the front and fun fact about this camera
since the camera is called the weapon
red actually offers a stealth option of
the weapon badge on the front for people
that travel with their cameras a lot and
don't want to go through airport
security with something with the word
weapon on it not so fun fact though I
still get stopped pretty much every time
anyway mostly because we also have to
have huge batteries in our bag anyway
the big difference
shading factor with this red camera is
how modular they are this is the actual
body of the camera and you can choose
exactly what accessories you want to use
to shoot so I have of course a battery
mount on the back plus the actual
battery plus the monitor and soon a top
handle but most times you see a red
camera it's rigged much more heavily
than mine since multiple people are
operating it but as a one-man crew I
keep things pretty nimble and I
absolutely love shooting with this thing
if you want sample footage see my last
few videos and the benefits of shooting
raw are real that's pretty dope alright
so the last thing is actually the secret
that you need to join team no-sleep to
be able to get infinite work done and
never have to recharge and that is to
just always be plugged in shameless plug
no this is actually the mkbhd version to
t-shirt it'll be live to buy for the
next two weeks
at the link right below that like button
so if you want to pick one up you can it
is available and then it'll be gone
forever
thank you for watching episode number
one of dope tech looking to have some
fun with this series and you should know
this is inspired entirely by the coolest
suck on the planet series by TLD TLD
channel is pretty awesome too the card
should be right around there you should
follow him subscribe to him super crispy
videos over there to inspire this one
and yeah if you guys have suggestions
for future episodes of dope tech that's
what the comments section is for thank
you for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace